I even know what to say in this intro so
I'm going to tell you that yeah I was
clipping the facial hair and then the
Clippers just broke and so I had to
shave it all so now it looks like baby
face half jeremy yeah I feel really
naked you see me for the nerd I am so
let's do this from you neighbors to
sorority rising so neighbors to is the
sequel to the first neighbors movie in
this movie Seth Rogen Rose burns
characters are selling their house and I
guess their house is in escrow which
pretty much means they have a buyer but
the buyer has 30 days to find a problem
and at any point he'll be like hey I
don't want to buy the house anymore
right at that moment a sorority headed
up by Chloe grace Moretz moves in right
next door and they're like hey we're
going to be the sorority that can party
I guess sororities aren't allowed to
party but they like screw that noise you
see that we got an all-female
Ghostbusters we're gonna be the sorority
that parties girl power so now they need
to get the sorority out of there so they
don't lose their buyer all right so
first of all Seth Rogen Seth Rogen is
still funny generally speaking I find
Seth Rogen funny although Seth Rogen is
always just Seth Rogen at this point but
hey it works but holy [ __ ] can we talk
about Zac Efron for a second Zac Efron
this guy has comedic prowess he
continues to show that he's really
really good at comedy the dude is just
growing as an actor I love seeing this
guy he's kind of a wild card in this
whole thing which is pretty much them
finding a reason to bring Zac Efron back
but he totally works for the premise in
here and I actually found his story or
at least his life in this phase in his
life kind of touching you know all his
friends have moved on they found careers
and he's the one who still kind of stuck
in the past so this situation gives him
something to do I kind of got where he
was coming from you know as a man-child
it's not always easy to grow up you know
even though you know you have to so you
just kind of stay put you're like that
is comfortable I like it here that's
just a monologue I'm not growing up
anytime soon screw that noise however
although this movie did bring the laughs
it didn't bring the laughs as much as
the first neighbors movie it's kind of a
bummer you want a sequel to step it up
this one actually took a step back for a
second not to say it's not funny I'm
just saying there were more irritating
ass things in his movie like in the
first neighbors movie I felt the
fraternity and Seth Rogen just had a
clash but it was just it was ultimately
Seth Rogen's like hey we need a good
night's sleep we have a new kid the kid
needs to sleep we want this thing out of
here for our own comfort now it's like
hey sorority we need
you out of there so we don't have two
mortgages and lose both houses it's like
a financial crisis on the line here so
immediately you're on Seth Rogen side
you actually kind of hate the sorority
for putting them in this position and
I'm sure the first neighbors movie if I
go into it again I can kind of nitpick
things like this but in this movie it
was more apparent it was more apparent
upfront there's like hey if you just
kind of went through the proper channels
you could get them out of there cuz you
see where the sorority steals all this
[ __ ] from their house and starts selling
it right there on the porch yeah call
the cops Seth Rogen's like oh we can't
we stole this other stuff and I want to
keep it bad because I want to spoil the
movie point is they stole stuff from
them but they burned all the evidence
there's no evidence of that
Alonzo Harris from training day taught
us all it's not what you know it's what
you can prove there's no proof of it it
didn't happen call the cops get him out
of there boom done there are a couple
scenarios maybe a few scenarios where
you're like nah you get out of that way
easier there's no need to go through
this [ __ ] the comedy really shines in
this movie from the one-liners that the
actors do a little an off-the-cuff
remark here and off-the-cuff remark
there that's where it's great I'm the
situational circumstance is funny but
it's kind of unevenly paced in parts but
in the end they pull it together and
they give you a touching story about
friendship once again that really kind
of transcends all the [ __ ] that is
glaring and you kind of look past all
the [ __ ] see the good [ __ ] it has
chuckles it pretty much comedy sequel as
you know most comedy passible comedy
sequels to be first one I thought was
great second one not as good but still
funny there is enjoyment here and I will
say neighbors two sorority rising is a
good time no alcohol required alright
guys so neighbors - have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's an
example of a comedy sequel that's better
than the first one for some odd reason
with a comedy that's just harder to do
but whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
you